So, I guess you could sum up optimizing
the critical rendering path, as having three main objectives.
Reducing the number of critical bytes. Reducing the number
of critical resources. And shortening the critical path length.
>> Exactly, so your job is to make the
critical rendering path as small and as short as possible.
>> Definitely, okay so I'm going to go back and run my page through
PageSpeed Insight again and this time I'll get some recommendations I can act on and
I can't wait to start optimizing my site.
>> Awesome, I'm glad to hear that. Web performance is a big topic
and there's a lot more to learn. So when you go through PageSpeed
Insights, make sure you follow the links to learn about other things. It
all adds up in the end. Are you ready to do the final project?
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Alright, now that we've taken the full
tour through the critical rendering path, I think
you've got all the tools you need to make. The site render as fast as possible,
ideally in under one second. And Cameron's portfolio site needs a lot of work.
If we run it through PageSpeed Insights, we see that it's scoring pretty low.
>> As a final challenge, use what you've learned in this class to help me
optimize my site. Your goal is to
improve the PageSpeed Insight score above a 90.
>> Right, and to do this you'll need to do a few things. First, fork the
projects Github repo. You can find a link
to it in the instructor notes. Then analyze
it using the techniques like drawing
the critical rendering path diagram and diagnosing
the. Protocol path metrics. Then apply
the optimizations. And publish it on GitHub
pages. If you're not familiar with GitHub, you can find some links in
the instructor notes helping you fork the repo and publish your site on GitHub.
>> Once you finish your optimizations. Run your
new and improved portfolio through the PageSpeed Insights.
You'll see all sorts of suggestions that should make some sense now, like
optimized CSS delivery and removed render
blocking JavaScript. When you think you've done
all the optimization you can, post what changes you made on the forums
along with the URL of your portfolio and the new PageSpeed Insights score.
>> And while you're at it, why don't you make
the portfolio page your own? You can use it to
showcase the projects you're proud of. We've got a link
in the instructor notes to help you out. Good luck.